all right on to another subject tonight
the nba's relationship with china now
remember it's been the subject of
intense controversy over the last few
years
after one of the league's top owners was
criticized after he tweeted a rather
innocuous comment in support of a free
hong kong and then lebron james piped in
and other people anyway a new report
from espn reveals just how much though
that the owners have at stake in china
40 principal owners of teams have 10
billion dollars in chinese investments
first to miami heat owner mickey arisen
he has more than 375 million dollars
tied up in china through his team and
his business carnival corporation the
world's largest cruise operator then
sacramento king's co-owner paul jacobs
total china exposure is at about 140
million dollars more than 30 percent of
his net worth mostly due to his
investments in qualcomm
then memphis grizzlies owner robert
perez exposure at china in china is at
about 369 million dollars through his
company ubiquity that's a wireless
equipment manufacturer whose operations
are based primarily in southern china
now houston rockets owner tillman
ferretta fritteta is the president and
ceo of landry's which operates 10
restaurants in china they generate an
estimated 57 million dollars in annual
sales his estimated total exposure to
china is over 160
million dollars and the biggest name of
them all is charlotte's uh charlotte
hornet's owner michael jordan who
donated 100 million dollars to social
justice efforts here in the united
states remember he has an estimated 85
million dollars wrapped up in china
now could that be part of the reason
we're hesitant to criticize china as we
criticize the united states joining me
now is an ed freedom former center for
the boston celtics and human rights
activists and as thank you for joining
us on your birthday by the way which is
my son's birthday today and he's only 12
years old happy birthday nico happy
birthday annez um where is the outrage
over this
first of all thank you for having me and
thank you so much for the shout out for
my birthday but you know first time i
read read about this article i was not
shocked at all i have been telling and
extremely exposed as people from day one
and it's just unbelievable how the world
and especially people in america that
has not some of the people in america
let me just you know fix myself
america has not wake up to this
hypocrisy you know 40 nba
owners are tied up around 10 billion
dollars in with the chinese government
and now people finally understand
understanding why they are talking about
all the social justice you know
problems are happening everywhere but
when it comes to china they are scared
to that it just seems like greed
overwhelms basic issues of right and
wrong once again
you know
it just people needs to understand and
it just
it's just so hard for me to something to
express myself because obviously i
played in the league for 11 years and i
was seeing the parkasy from first hand
and it doesn't matter you know human
rights violence is happening in america
all around the world we have to call
them out like it is you know
and you know moral matters for the mba
moral matters until
money or business are involved so that
is the one thing that was breaking my
heart and all these owners there are 50
nba owners are making profit off of a
slave labor so we have to call them out
because they love to sit down and give
us this all the social justice uh you
know talk to us but in reality they're
scared
they're only talking about the things
that happen in america but when it comes
to they when the the the things that
they is
talk about their money in your pocket
they're gonna stay silent and we have to
keep expose them and another uh uh
tidbit from that report from espn ns is
the brooklyn nets owner joe tsai now he
was born in hong kong and obviously
strong ties to china uh in the face of
this nba's uneasy relationship with
china said donates hundreds of millions
of dollars to combat racism and
discrimination in the united states but
in china of course this company partners
with other companies that are
blacklisted by the us government for
supporting a campaign of repression mass
arbitrary detention and high-tech
surveillance through state-of-the-art
racial profiling i think that's facial
profiling uh and it's uh
your reaction to that just that issue
exactly i mean he is probably the worst
of them all you know i think he is the
owner of alibaba and he's pretty much
working for the uh ccp
and uh i mean i have i did hear a lot of
stories about him and how much he loves
to you know do social justice work well
only in america but obviously when it
comes to uh china just because of his
billion dollars are involved he's scared
to that he cannot
say a word and shame on him i will just
say it like it is shame on him but
uh
it just i just wish just only please god
send me one more player to just stand by
me so we can just expose this uh whole
truth and show the whole world that
what's really going on thank you so much
great to see you happy birthday hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else